get ready for a bit of a bummer true
believers mighty Marvel might be running
like a well-oiled machine but according
to writer director James Gunn it's going
to take a little longer than we might
like for that machine to pump out
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 in a
recent exchange with a fan on Instagram
Gunn revealed that the three quill for
the spacefaring team of misfits won't
start filming for quote another year or
so the news isn't entirely unexpected as
we've known for quite some time that
Gunn will have a bit of work to wrap up
for the distinguished competition before
he can turn his attention to guardians 3
as you may recall the director was
temporarily fired from the Marvel flick
due to a kerfuffle over some nearly
decade old tweets in 2018 he was
reinstated in March 2019 but in the
meantime he had taken a gig with Warner
Brothers and DC films writing and
directing the soft reboot the Suicide
Squad Marvel in no hurry to rush
Guardians 3 to the screen with it's late
already chock-full a loud gun to finish
up his work on the DC film before
returning according to CB our gun has
said that shooting on the Suicide Squad
is only about two-thirds complete as
recently as December 18th assuming the
flick sticks to its production schedule
it's likely to wrap by February or so at
which point gun will be knee-deep in the
post-production process for another
several months of course nobody would
blame Gunn if he wanted to cool his Jets
for just a while before taking on
another massive comic book film so his
stated timeframe for guardians 3 to
begin production sounds just about right
however assuming that shooting does
indeed get underway in late 2020 we can
infer that we've got a pretty damn long
wait before the flick actually hits
theaters consider that the Suicide Squad
has been slotted for release on August
6th 2021 this means that from wrap to
release we're looking at a period of
about 16 months if guardians 3 has a
fairly typical three to four month shoot
then it will wrap right around March or
April of 2021 and if it has a comparable
post production schedule the very
earliest we could expect to see it hit
screens is July or August of 2022 the
sequel to Black Panther is already
slated for release on may 6th of that
year and Marvel has a
number of other films that might
shoulder their way into its two
remaining 2022 slots including blade and
the third installment of the ant-man
series it follows then the guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 may not even appear in
theaters until sometime in 2023 more
than three years from now guess we'll
all just have to pop into hibernation
for a bit huh do one of those on me
[Music]
while the emcee used feature schedule is
all sewn up through blacc panther2 there
are still a number of flicks in addition
to those already mentioned that don't
yet have release dates perhaps the most
high-profile is Captain Marvel - the
sequel to the 2019 billion-dollar smash
which will see brie Larson reprise her
role as the uber powerful cosmic hero
also heavily rumored to be an active
development is Nova a solo vehicle for
the even more powerful hero who should
have an intimate connection to the
Guardians essentially Marvel's answer to
DC's Green Lantern the man called Nova
is Richard Ryder an Earthling imbued
with the power of the entire Nova Corps
cosmically powered Armed Forces of the
planets and are as you may recall Xander
came under threat by the Infinity stone
wielding Ronan the accuser in the first
guardians film and the comics writer is
chosen at random by the Zen Darian Roman
day to house the power of the Nova Corps
after the planets destruction Ryder is
also imbued with the Zen darian world
mind basically the collective knowledge
of the entire Zen darian rates
that's right Nova is basically the most
robust supercomputer one can imagine a
supercomputer that can punch a planet
out of its orbit King geek and marvel
mastermind Kevin Feige has also recently
teased that there is indeed another team
of film on the way although he
characteristically held back any
relevant details since Marvel's phases
are running a bit shorter now phase 4 is
taking place over 2020 and 2021 with
phase 5
taking up 2022 and 2023 it seems likely
that we'll be getting an official
announcement on this sometime pretty
soon unless it gets pushed off until
phase 6
at any rate we'll just have to wait
until Feige and companies see their way
clear to cluing us in on when we can
expect the guardians of the galaxy blade
Captain Marvel ant-man in the wasp Nova
and the Avengers whatever the heck the
next iteration of that team will look
like to return to theaters of course
will be all over any breaking Marvel
news and we'll be sure to keep you
informed check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]